I would say the biggest challenge I have
as a woman in science is a be a mom it's
really hard it's very hard work having
children and I tell kids this all the
time they say what's the hardest thing
you've ever done because I've done so
many space missions and Hubble and prime
your big project like all the hardest
thing is being a mom it's like 24-7 you
can't stop and it's always there and as
a scientist it's hard because you know
my particular field of science and most
fields of science require quite a bit of
dedication to whether it's laboratory
work or in my case telescopic work where
I need to go places and do things having
high quality day care is by far the most
important thing you can do when your
kids are little you know I when I
relocated I spent more time looking for
daycare than I did looking for a house
it was much more important to have good
day care and I was fortunate to find
high quality day care where I just
totally trusted it then my kids were
great they absolutely fantastic kids
doing super jobs now and you know
they're wonderful but you know I had to
spend a lot of time and energy doing
that I also learned you must rely on
friends and family to help you out you
can't do it on your own you know there's
just people like y'all you how do you do
it I'm like well my neighbors my mom
helps you know I just rely on other
people that's the way it has to be
otherwise you just go nuts so it's it's
a tough balancing act and I also learned
that there is no such thing as balance
that you know on any individual day your
life is completely skewed one way or the
other one day you're like dealing with
child crises and you're just coping and
the next day you know you may be dealing
with a work crisis and just dealing with
that over the long run you have to find
sort of the right balance but you can't
expect it to balance in the individual
moment because it won't and once you
learn to give that up once you learn to
give up the myth of balance
you know you can be a much more relaxed
person I would encourage anybody who's
interested in any kind of science and
engineering math field to go after that
you know I am not about telling people
become astronomers we don't need a lot
of astronomers but what I want to avoid
is that young young woman coming along
who was absolutely fascinated in
biochemistry but she's told uh no
biochemistry that's the guys field
that's wrong you know and I the best
compliment I ever had was a young person
who I just met standing in line to go to
a concert it was like two years after
the shoemaker-levy 9 thing where I had
been in the news a lot and this guy and
all we were talking waiting to get in
the concert and he said no I am I
introduced myself hiding him looks like
are you Heidi the Heidi him with the
astronomer I'm like yeah that's what
he's like ah you're the reason i'ma i
became a biologist I said oh yeah how'd
that happen he said well when you did
that comet crash thing I just thought
that was so cool and I had really
slacked off I dropped out of college and
I was just you know being a slacker but
I was so excited by that that I went
back to college and I took astronomy
courses and I said well that's pretty
cool he said yeah but I hated astronomy
like well it's not for everyone he said
I loved biology and I went on to get my
PhD in biology I'm like that's it that's
what it's all about you know that's my
message is don't be discouraged by
anything anybody tells you you know in
my case that's the science thing and I
just ignored people who said Oh girls
don't do that or what would la I just
went ahead and do it anyway you know
lack of fear stupidity I don't know why
I just kept doing it but to tell young
people don't listen to those folks so
you can't if you want to do it
that's the message I tried